GERBRAND CEDER: --recap
a little the introduction
to Monte Carlo.
And then, I want to show you
in different types of systems,
systems with different
types of degrees of freedom,
how you would implement
a Monte Carlo move.
And then towards the end,
depending on how far we get,
I'll talk a little about
error analysis in Monte Carlo
and also about things like
free energy integration
and how to detect phase
transitions in Monte Carlo.
OK.
I wanted to go through the
list of references first.
For general
statistical mechanics,
the books I particularly like
are David Chandler's book
and Don McQuarrie's book.
Those of you who've
taken 320 with me,
Statistical Thermodynamics is
exactly the book we use in 320.
But if you've never sort
of seen the relation
between statistical
mechanics and thermo,
then I would really
recommend to Dave Chandler's
little green book.
It's really sort of an
excellent but short tutorial,
I think, to modern
statistical mechanics.
More specifically
on the Monte Carlo,
my favorite is the book by
Franklin Smith, which I think
is now in a second edition.
I sort of noticed that
people had a book that
looked very different.
If it's anywhere like
the first edition,
I thought it was a
really good book.
I think it's a little deeper
than all of the other books
I've seen on Monte Carlo.
Because of that, it may
look a little more abstract
on some occasions.
And because these
guys are chemists,
it tends to focus heavily on
molecular systems rather than
solid state.
But I think it's a
great book to learn
the proper statistical
mechanics and sort
of the theory of Monte Carlo.
The Newman book is
pretty good as well.
And then a classic
for Monte Carlo books
is all the books by Binder.
Binder has actually
several books--
Kurt Binder-- at least four or
five, some thick, some thin.
And Binder's expertise
is essentially
Monte Carlp and lattice models.
I mean, he does
other stuff as well,
but that's really where
his expertise lie.
And in particular,
long chain molecules,
for example if you do
polymers on lattice models.
And I'll show an
example of that.
Binder's book is great for that.
But he has the standard
introduction in there
with lattice models with
Ising like-- so spin models,
how to do the statistical
mechanics of those,
how to look at transitions.
It's a great reference if
you're first starting out.
OK.
So let me sort of recap
how we got to Monte Carlo.
Remember that we talked
about an ensemble
as a collection of the
microscopic states that
really belong to one
macroscopic state.
So the macroscopic state is
thermodynamically defined.
The ensemble is the collection
of microscopic states
that the system goes
through for a given
set of thermodynamic
boundary conditions.
The probability that your
state is in a given system
is the exponential minus
beta, the Hamiltonian,
normalized by the
partition function.
And so the way you
track averages is simply
by averaging the property
over the microstates
with the relevant probability.
We distinguish two
types of sampling--
and I'll come back to this later
to show you intermediates--
simple sampling, where you would
randomly pick in the ensemble,
and then weigh the property--
let's say that A is
the property you're
trying to average--
with the correct probability.
And I've shown you
why in many cases,
in systems with a large
number of degrees of freedom,
why simple sampling
will not work.
Because you will tend
to pick the states that
have high degeneracy--
so the type of states that have
high frequency of occurrence,
not the states that necessarily
determine your average well.
And the classic example is
if you take the spin model--
if you're in a low
temperature state,
the dominant states are
the ferromagnetic states.
Whereas if you randomly
picked spin states,
you would all pick
disordered states.
You would barely
ever have any states
with significant
ferromagnetic patches.
So that's why we went
to importance sampling.
And importance
sampling is essentially
you try to pick the
states in your sample
immediately with the
correct probability
or with a rate
that's proportional
to the correct probability.
So if you pick them
with the proper rate,
you really just average the
property you're getting.
Because these already occur
in the sample with a frequency
proportional to the
correct probability.
That's the idea of
importance sampling.
OK.
So I've shown you how a
typical Metropolis algorithm
with Boltzmann's
sampling would work.
You would start with
some configuration
in the system, which could
be pretty much anything.
You would choose a
perturbation of the system--
and I'll do a lot more
examples of what these can be.
You compute the energy
of that perturbation.
If the energy goes down,
you accept the perturbation.
If the energy goes
up, you accept it
with a probability of
the Boltzmann factor--
so the exponential minus
beta delta E-- and then
you kind of circle around.
It's not totally clear who first
developed modern Monte Carlo,
but it's often attributed to
Metropolis in this famous paper
Metropolis, Rosenbluth,
Rosenbluth, Teller, and Teller.
Her I know these Tellers
were husband and wife.
I'm not sure about the
Rosenbluth, but I also saw--
these were couples
doing research together.
And no surprise, the sort of
modern version of Monte Carlo
essentially started with
the advent of computers.
Because to do the
statistical sampling,
essentially what you
need was a computer.
So the time frame
is about the same.
I give you one
example of a model
that I'm going to come back to,
the Ising spin model, where you
literally have up and down
spins on given lattice sites
with a simple
interaction Hamiltonian.
And the reason these
models are nice,
you can very quickly calculate
the excitation energy.
So for example, if you were
in a ferromagnetic state--
so a central spin is
surrounded by four up spins,
so in a ferromagnetic state--
you can easily calculate
what the spin flip energy
is of these.
Here you have four
parallel bonds.
If you flip this over, you
have four antiparallel bonds
So the delta E is essentially
8 times the bond energy,
assuming this case
eta j is positive.
So an excitation occurs with the
rate of exponential minus beta
delta E.
If you ever want to play games
and try to write really, really
fast Monte Carlo code, if you
just have a nearest neighbor
interaction, you see that the
number of different excitation
energies you can
get is very finite.
Because there's really
only a small number
of possible nearest
neighbor environments.
And so what you can
do is tabulate them.
You can tabulate
their exponential
at a given temperature.
And so then you save
all the calculations
of these exponentials.
And you can write extremely
fast Monte Carlo code.
This is code where you can
easily reach 100 million
spin flip attempts per second.
So you can do, just for the
fun of it, amazing statistics.
You can keep on doing that.
It's something to keep
in mind, that if you're
going to do Monte Carlo
where speed becomes
an issue, sometimes if you
have discrete environments,
it can be efficient to
tabulate them ahead of time.
Because if you
can tabulate them,
you can tabulate their energy.
That means you can
tabulator exponential,
and there's a big chunk
of time you tend to save.
The way we implement
the probability
is with random numbers.
And I want to come
back to that issue
that I brought up last
time, because I may have not
been very clear from
the comments I got.
Normally, random number
generation works pretty well,
but there's one issue.
So remember, the
way you implement
a probability is that
you take a random number,
say between 0 and 1, and
when that random number
is less than the exponential,
then you execute.
I've really got to
calibrate this pen.
But the way random
numbers are typically
made in a lot of computers is
that you don't generate reals,
you generate integers,
and typically between 0
and some largest
integer 2n minus 1
depending on the type of
random number generator.
And then you divide
that by 2 to the n
to get the real between 0 and 1.
But what that means
is that you really
have a set of discrete
real random numbers,
and they start from 0--
1 over 2 to the n
2 over 2 to the n.
So the important part of this is
that on occasion will cause you
trouble is that you draw 0
with a certain probability,
with a finite probability, which
is actually 1 over 2 to the n
you get 0.
And you may think
that's not a problem,
but the problem is that whenever
your random number is 0,
you will execute any
perturbation you attempt.
So if you have a perturbation
algorithm that can occasionally
pick very high
energy perturbations,
normally that's a
safe thing to do.
Because if your random number
generation was continuous,
tat means you would never
hit 0, and the probability
of hitting 0 is essentially 0.
Then that would
never be accepted.
OK.
But because of the discreetness
of the random number generator,
you do accept that.
And so this is a great way of
sort of blowing up your system.
I mean, you could imagine,
let's say, for some silly reason
you could occasionally do
perturbation atoms in a liquid,
where you put all the
atoms on top of each other.
So that would be a very
high energy perturbation.
It would never be accepted.
But here it would be accepted
at a rate of 1 over 2 to the n.
And usually, that
means that in a sort
of regular set of
samplings, you tend
to do typically more
than 2 to the n passes
for a reasonable random
number generator.
You will actually
hit up on that .
I want to come back to
what the quantity is,
what essentially the
Hamiltonian is very briefly.
So if you did a lattice
model where you can actually
change the overall spin--
so you're flipping up
spin and down spin--
you would typically have a
field term in the Hamiltonian.
So you have the
interaction term,
and then you have a field term.
You can think of it as
a chemical potential
for the spin which try to
essentially force the spin
to have a given average value.
And you would put that full in
some almost Legendre transform
of the Hamiltonian
into the exponential.
And I showed you last
time how you actually
get the quantity that
goes into the exponential.
For example, if you were to
work at constant temperature,
pressure, and
number of particles,
your Hamiltonian,
the exponential,
would be the energy
pV or minus pV.
OK.
What I will do now is tell you
a little about the problem we're
going to give you in the lab.
I think the lab is still like
more than a week away because
of scheduling.
We had to move it back.
But I want to show you,
introduce you to, the problem
we're going to solve there.
Essentially, what
we're going to do
is an absorption model for
hydrogen on a palladium
1 0 0 surface.
And palladium is an FCC metal.
So the 1 0 0 surface
is essentially
a centered square lattice.
Remember, it's if you take the
0 0 1 plane of the FCC cube,
it's the centered
square lattice.
Which if you rotate
it 45 degrees,
it's a simple square lattice.
So that's going to make
this at least topologically
a very simple model.
We're going to have
a square lattice,
and we're going to look at
hydrogen absorption on that.
So the question is really,
at every lattice site--
so I can't really draw on
the lattice sites anymore--
is there a hydrogen
there or not?
Typically, you'll see
that written in what's
called a lattice Hamiltonian.
And a lattice Hamiltonian
has occupation variables
which are either 1 or 0.
So 1 when the site is
occupied by hydrogen,
0 when the site is not occupied.
So only when you have two
occupations across a bond
length, say i and j, will you
actually get interaction energy
between the two hydrogens.
So you can write your
Hamiltonian as something
like sum over i j bonds.
And i j, you could have
the restriction here, say,
that i j are nearest neighbor.
So then you just have a near
neighbor interaction W1.
So that gives you
the interaction
between the hydrogen.
And then if you do
this is an open system,
you have a chemical
potential-like term,
which you think of as the
absorption energy for hydrogen
but which is essentially the
difference between absorption
energy and whatever
chemical potential you have
in your source of hydrogen. But
in the end it's just a number
times--
this is the total amount of
hydrogen on your surface--
some i p i.
You can transform this to a
lattice model Hamiltonian.
I don't know if everybody's
familiar with that.
Essentially we like to work
with lattice model Hamiltonians,
so we do the spin
transformation.
Sigma i is-- how
does it go again--
2 p i minus 1.
So if p i is 1,
then sigma i is 1.
And if p i is 0, then
sigma i is minus 1.
So you transform the variables.
And if you substitute--
so you invert this,
that means that p i is
1 plus sigma i over 2.
If you substitute
that in here, you
transform your lattice
model Hamiltonian
to a spin Hamiltonian.
And what you'll see
is the interactions,
the relation between the
interactions V1 in the spin
model.
And in the lattice model, the
interaction of the spin model
is a factor of 4 smaller
than the interaction
with the lattice model.
And the chemical potential
in the spin model
also relate to the absorption
energy in the latice model.
It's useful to keep these
transformations in mind,
because this one, a spin
model is often mathematically
much easier to deal with
than a lattice model.
But the lattice model,
it's often easier
to interpret the quantities
in a physical sense.
And the reason is
that here you only
have interaction when i and
j are occupied by hydrogen.
So W is sort of a true
hydrogen-hydrogen interaction
on the surface.
In a spin model,
you have terms here
for any occupation of i and j.
When i and j are
hydrogen, then you
have the interaction energy V1.
When i and j are both vacant,
so they're minus 1 minus 1,
you also have plus 1.
So you also have
the interaction V1.
And then when you just have
a hydrogen at either i or j,
so you have plus 1 and minus
1, then you get minus V1.
So it's harder to interpret
these constants physically.
We always tend to use
spin models though,
because they're mathematically
much more elegant.
And the reason is that
the variable is symmetric.
The variable is symmetric
around 0, plus 1 and minus 1,
which gives you a lot
of useful properties.
OK.
I must draw too much.
OK, here we go.
Like I mentioned already before,
to equilibrate the system--
essentially what your
assignment is going to be
for a Hamiltonian that's a
little more complicated than
the one I've shown you-- it's
actually going to be a first
and second neighbor Hamiltonian,
and the interactions were
calculated on paper from
electronic structure--
I want you to essentially get
the phase diagram for hydrogen
absorption on palladium 1 0 0.
So that means, as a function of
coverage, how much of the sites
are current temperature, what
the phase diagram looks like.
And again, to
equilibrate that, you
have to keep in
mind that it's much
faster to do grand
canonical ensemble
than canonical ensemble.
So an obvious way that you
may think of doing this
is if you plot the hydrogen
coverage versus temperature.
You may think of like
initializing a system
at a given hydrogen coverage
and then just sort of heating it
and looking at it.
The problem there occurs when
you're in two-phase regions.
If you're in a canonical
system and you're
in a two-phase
region, your system
has to phase separate
within your cell.
So for example,
that means it may
make a region with
a lot of hydrogen
and a region with less
hydrogen. And so what happens
is that if you're in
a two-phase region
you need a boundary in
your cell, essentially
a phase boundary.
And the phase
boundary, a boundary
carries energy with it.
And because the system
here is really small,
maybe you'll do a 40 by 40
cell, or something, or even 100
by 100 cell--
this is really small.
So the boundary has a
non-negligible effect
on your total energy.
Whereas in reality,
in real systems,
the patches that coexist
would be much bigger,
and so the boundary would have,
proportionately, a much smaller
energy contribution.
So if you do
canonical and you're
in these two-phase
regions, your energy
will depend somewhat
on your system size.
Because the system size--
with system size, I mean the
size of the Monte Carlo box--
determines the relative
proportion of boundary
to perfect system.
And so you'll get
a different energy.
So it's much better to
do canonical simulations,
where you essentially assume
some hydrogen chemical
potential and use
as the Hamiltonian
some interactions, some i
j, V i j, sigma i sigma j,
so you have an
interaction term, and then
you just control the
amount of hydrogen
with a chemical potential
term, mu H, some i, sigma i.
So how will you see
phase boundaries then?
Well, essentially at
a given temperature
you just tweak mu H,
the chemical potential.
This is just like
in an experiment
where you would control
the gas pressure.
And you may start--
if you start with
very high mu H--
this actually makes
a little more sense,
I guess, if I use a minus.
So if I start with very low
mu H, so very negative mu H,
then I want this to be low.
So then the spin is going
to drift to minus 1.
And depending on what you've
defined to be hydrogen,
if you define minus 1 to be a
vacant side, a plus 1 hydrogen,
you're going to drift--
your system is going to tend
towards having no hydrogen.
And as you crank up
your chemical potential,
you'll get more and more
hydrogen in your system.
But the nice thing is that if
you have two-phase regions,
you'll essentially
jump across them.
So let me give you an example.
Let's say that this
phase diagram simply
looked like this.
But I'll tell you
already, it doesn't.
But it's a sort
of simple example.
Let's say it was just
sort of a miscibility gap.
So at low temperature
you have states--
this is essentially the
state here with no hydrogen,
and this is full coverage.
And so in here you
have coexistence
between patches of full
coverage and no hydrogen.
If you do this by cranking
up the chemical potential,
you will essentially sort
of move from here to here.
From no hydrogen, you'll
move to this phase boundary,
and then you'll jump across
to this phase boundary.
And you will never live
in the two-phase region.
So let me actually plot that.
If you were to plot
the hydrogen coverage
as a function of the
chemical potential,
you'll essentially
go up very small.
And then at some critical
chemical, potential
you'll jump up and then
you'll sort of go to 1.
And this discontinuity
here, that's
the width of your
two-phase region.
So you never live in
a two-phase region
when you grand canonical,
because you work only
with intensive variables
in your thermodynamics.
So you essentially jump across
the first-order transitions,
rather than living in
the discontinuity that
defines them.
So it tends to be much
more efficient to get
phase diagrams.
OK.
One of the nice aspects
of Monte Carlo simulation
is that because
it's a simulation
method with essentially
no approximations
in the approach--
there are essentially
no approximations
in the Metropolis algorithm--
so you can get the answer
as accurately as you want.
Or as accurately
as you can afford
is probably a better
way to say it.
So where do inaccuracies
come from when
you do Monte Carlo sampling?
So we're going to talk about the
inaccuracies of the integration
of the ensemble averaging.
So we're not going to
talk about the inaccuracy
of the Hamiltonian
you start with,
that's something you take.
You're going to ensemble
average some properties
defined by Hamilton.
If the Hamiltonian is
not accurate, well,
we're not going
to deal with that.
But the question is, how
accurate is the sampling?
Well, you get sources
from two things--
the fact that you take a finite
time sample or a finite sample,
so you don't really
collect the whole ensemble,
and you tend to work
with finite size.
Finite size is a
bit of a misnomer.
Unfortunately, we all use it.
Because if you use periodic
boundary conditions, of course
your system is always infinite.
It's just that you have
imposed a periodicity on it.
So the error really comes
from imposed periodicity.
But but we just tend to call
them finite size effects.
If you set up a
20 by 20 lattice,
you can't get any things in
there that have periodicity 35.
It won't fit in there.
You can't get any
truly random things.
In anything with periodic
boundary conditions,
you don't have truly
random things, because you
force that that unit repeats.
And to get in more
and more random,
you can make the box
bigger so the repeat
period becomes longer.
But in the end, it's
all non-periodic.
So you can't truly simulate
a random liquid, say.
Notice that you
also impose symmetry
from your periodic
boundary condition.
If you take, let's say,
in 3D, a cubic cell
and you simulate
a liquid in there,
what's the symmetry
of that system?
What's the symmetry of
a liquid, a real liquid?
It has a perfect spherical
symmetry actually.
It's point group, it has
perfect spherical symmetry.
Every direction is identical.
So it's higher than
cubic symmetry actually.
But what do you do?
You impose cubic symmetry.
Because you essentially have a
cubic lattice of a repeat unit
that you displace.
For a lot of properties,
this won't matter at all.
But it's just something
to keep in mind.
So you get errors
from your sample time
and from your finite or your
periodic boundary conditions--
put it like that way.
The sampling error
is the easiest one
to deal with, because you
can quantify it if you really
want to work on it.
Having said that,
let me tell you,
most people who run [INAUDIBLE]
just run it long enough
and hope it's long enough.
Rarely ever do you see
this quantitative analysis.
But I want to show you
that you can actually
do it if you really wanted to.
It's essentially a
very basic statistic.
So we're only going to
talk about averages so far.
Because the errors
on quantities that
are not available, like heat
capacity, and free energy,
and so on, entropy,
we'll come to later.
So I'm only going to
talk about quantities
that exist in the
microscopic state,
and the macroscopic
value is just
the average over the
microscopic defined variables--
so things like a volume or
an energy or a concentration.
So if you want to the
average for some property A,
I'm going to use different
terminology here.
When I write A
with a bar on top,
I mean the true average
of A in the ensemble.
So the ensemble gives you
some distribution of A's.
A bar is the true average,
and A between these brackets
is the average I actually
collect in my finite sample.
And the question is,
how different are those?
Well, that's basic statistics.
You know that A fluctuates
with some spread
around the true average.
So you have some
standard deviation,
which is the standard deviation
of A in the distribution.
For example, if
the property here
was the energy we
were looking at,
that standard deviation is
essentially the heat capacity.
Heat capacity is a measure
of the standard deviation
in the ensemble.
So if you take a finite
sample in this distribution,
you will not get
the true average,
but you'll get
some other average.
If you do that a
lot of times, you
can actually see how the average
you sample is distributed.
And if the sample you
take is uncorrelated,
then you know that the standard
deviation on the average
is essentially the
standard deviation
on the distribution divided
by the square root of M.
So I've written it
here with squares.
The square of the average,
the standard deviation
on the average,
goes like the square
on the standard deviation
of the distribution
divide by M, which M
is the sample size.
Is everybody familiar with that?
OK.
Essentially, if you
come you pick averages
from a distribution--
this could be some population--
that distribution itself
has a standard deviation.
Not everybody sits at the mean.
So if you only take
say three or four--
let's say you sample with
only three or four members--
you're going to get some
average for that distribution.
But you won't be right.
So if you do that many times--
you take many times
a sample of four--
you're going to get different
values of the average.
And if you plot how that
average is distributed,
that also tends
to be a Gaussian.
If your original
distribution is a Gaussian,
your average is a Gaussian.
And you can look at the root
mean square distribution
at the standard deviation
for your average.
And it turns out that if
your sample is uncorrelated,
they relate like this.
Now, why is that useful?
Because you actually
have all these quantities
in your simulation.
In your simulation, you
actually get some idea
about the standard deviation
on the distribution,
because you take a
very large sample.
You can average
it by essentially
the standard deviation
in your sample.
So you essentially say
that the standard deviation
I get in my sample
is going to be
pretty close to the standard
deviation of the distribution.
And then if the sample
size, you have an idea
of the error on your average.
So this you get in
your simulation,
because you can easily--
this is the average
of A squared.
This is what you get
in your distribution.
But you can also keep
track of A squared average.
There is one caveat.
So this is true if the samples
you take are uncorrelated.
So it means that if you
really randomly pick
from the ensemble.
The problem is that in a
Markov chain that we set up
through a Metropolis
algorithm, the samples
are not uncorrelated.
Because every step
in a Markov chain
comes from the previous one.
And you can sort
of see why that is.
Let's say I did Monte
Carlo on a liquid
and I did really
small perturbations.
So I just moved the
atom within a range
of a tenth of an Angstrom
or something like that.
So that way I will almost
always accept the moves.
But obviously my states
are very correlated.
One state in a
Markov chain just has
one atom displaced 0.1
Angstrom from the other one.
So I have a high
degree of correlation.
Correlation reduces the
quality of your sampling.
Actually, the extreme limit
is if you do perturbations
with very high energy
in a Markov chain,
they will almost
never be accepted.
And then your Markov chain
just has identical states
for a long time.
Because if you don't
accept the state,
you actually keep the old
one in the Markov chain.
So you have a high
degree of correlation.
So the quality of a sample
gets polluted by what's
called the correlation time.
And the correlation time
is, again, something
you can calculate essentially
with this equation.
And what does it measure?
What is correlation
time, in case
you're not familiar with it.
If I look at a quantity, let's
say as a function of time A T,
and time could be here
sample length, the distance
in my Markov chain.
Let's say I sort of get a bunch
of points scattered like this.
You're essentially
trying to measure
if what comes at any time
T that can be predicted
from what you had
at some T here,
where this is t minus tau.
If it can be, then what
happens at T and T minus tau
are correlated, and they're
correlated over a distance tau.
And so that's what
you're doing here.
What you're doing
here is you're looking
at whether-- this is
the perturbation away
from equilibrium.
This is how far A is away
from equilibrium at time
T. Let's not call
it equilibrium.
Let's call it the
average-- sorry.
And this is how far A is
away from the average at time
T plus tau.
And so you're seeing if
these are correlated.
You're looking at how
this fluctuation looks
like when you're normalizing
by the overall fluctuations
in the system.
So the correlation function
essentially measures
over what time you
keep correlation.
So for example in a liquid where
the system over a long time A
is purely randomly, you'll have
of course short correlation
time.
Probably in a real
liquid after a picosecond
the system still has a
lot of memory from time 0.
But after a whole second,
maybe it doesn't anymore.
So you'll have a finite
correlation time.
And this is what
you'll typically see.
If you plot correlation
time for systems
with some degree
of disorder, it'll
start out at 1,
because that's the way
this function is normalized,
and then sort of go down.
There are systems where the
correlation time is infinite.
If you have a perfect
harmonic oscillator
and you look at, say, the
velocity of a harmonic
oscillator versus T, since
this is a periodic system,
it just sort of
oscillates back and forth.
And if the period, if
the harmonic oscillator's
perfect, then once I know
what happens at one time,
I can exactly predict what
happens at another time.
So that system has an
infinite correlation time.
Essentially, what happens is
that the quality of the average
gets diluted by the
correlation time.
If you have correlation
in your sample,
the standard deviation on the
average is what we had before.
This is the standard deviation
on the uncorrelated sample,
but it gets multiplied by
essentially a factor that
depends on the correlation time.
And the correlation
time is the integral
of the correlation function.
So it's sort of the
integrated time over which
you have correlation.
So these are all things that are
relatively easy to calculate.
It actually costs you
no more computing time
to keep track of all
these things essentially.
This can be done
by post-processing,
this correlation time.
If you output the
trajectory A T,
you can do this simply
by post-processing,
and it's a fairly
fast operation.
So if you are
interested, you can
look at the quality
of your averages.
Like I said, most people
just kind of eyeball it.
I want to show you
a few correlation
times in this lattice
model, spin model.
This is actually from
your homework assignment,
from the lab assignment.
So it's actually
correlation time
in this hydrogen on
palladium system.
Because I kind of
learned a lesson from it
myself that I hadn't
figured out until I started
doing this homework problem.
And I should tell you
something up front.
Random number generation
is expensive in a computer.
It takes time, because the
sort of fraction algorithm
that calculates it does
quite a few operations, quite
a few multiplications.
So especially if your
energy calculation is fast--
like if you did
this lattice model,
this magnetic spin
model, 95% of the time
would be spent in the
random number generator.
The rest is all so fast.
So people often
try to do shortcuts
to reduce the number of random
numbers you have to take.
Because think about it, you
have to take quite a few.
Let's say you do a
three-dimensional spin model.
First of all, you
have to randomly pick
a spin you're trying to perturb.
That takes three random numbers.
So you have to randomize
three, x, y, z.
And then you need a
fourth random number
to compare with the exponential
of minus beta delta E.
So that's four and
the numbers per pass.
So that's not what
we usually do.
Here's what we usually do--
we don't randomly pick
spins in the lattice,
we run through the
latter sequentially.
Because it kills three
random number operations.
So you just kind of go.
And most of the time that works
out fine, except this time.
So here's the correlation
time in a lattice model.
This is actually the
hydrogen on palladium
at different temperatures.
And the scale down here is the
number of Monte Carlo passes.
So this is correlation time
in units of Monte Carlo time.
Which is 1 unit of time is one
pass through the whole lattice.
So if you have a 10 by 10,
it's 100 perturbations.
If you have a 100 by 100,
it'd be 10,000 perturbations.
That's one unit of time.
And to give you an
idea, this is a system,
at these conditions it undergoes
a second-order transition
near about somewhere T's eight
or nine or something like that.
So below that you're in an
ordered state, above that
you're in a disordered state.
So let's first look at
the low temperature.
So you're in an order state--
you actually have very
short correlation time.
It goes down very quickly to 0.
And then there's this
spurious oscillations--
I'll show you in a second
where to come from.
which is really weird,
because you wouldn't you
don't expect large
correlation times
at either low or
high temperature.
Basically at either
low temperature
you barely have
any fluctuations,
and at very high temperature
everything is so random
that it's uncorrelated.
It's at intermediate temperature
that you have the longest
correlation and in particular
near-phase transitions.
You sort of see the
same thing a T equals 0.
Correlation time
is a little longer.
Remember, the
correlation time is
the integral under this curve.
And then you got
these fluctuations.
And then 0at T equals 8, you're
very close to the transition.
You see now you have a
fairly high degree of fairly
long correlation time.
I mean, if you sort of
eyeball the integration here,
we'd almost have a
triangle from 1 to 15.
So we'd have, what, about 7
and 1/2 under this integral?
So that means that the
quality of your averaging
here has almost gone
down by a factor of 10
from what you would get if
you did a random sample.
It's actually more.
Because, remember, the
quality of the average
goes down by a factor 1 plus
2 times the correlation time.
So if we have 7 and 1/2, we
have a factor of 16 there.
So the quality of
our average is pretty
poor near the
second-order transition.
And then at high
temperature, it goes--
you really have a
short correlation time.
Now, the reason I keep
this bad data up here,
because it's a
mistake I made myself.
The spurious
fluctuations, at first
I thought they were noise.
But they're obviously
way too big to be noise.
And they don't go away when
you take a longer sample.
So if they're
noise, then I think,
well, I got an order
of magnitude longer.
They don't go away.
Those fluctuations stay,
and they can't be real.
At T equals 2, you can't
have correlation over 20.
And why would you have
correlation time over at 20
but not 15?
And so these actually
come from sequentially
stepping through the lattice.
What actually happens
is that your lattice
starts locking in with the
random number generator.
So your random number
generator has a period to it.
And if you sequentially
step through the lattice,
you're visiting every site at
a given periodicity of time.
And at some point, that
periodicity of time
started locking in
with the periodicity
of the random number generator.
Which really what it's saying
is that certain spins are not
randomly flipped
anymore, because they
occur at a certain time scale
in the random number generator.
And all random number generators
have a period in them,
and that's what causes this.
So you can easily solve it if
you just randomly pick spins.
Another way you can do it if
you want to sort of have it
both ways, the things
we do now sometimes
is that you can just
once in a while randomly
jump ahead in the
random number generator.
Or you can randomly jump
ahead in the spins you
touch in the lattice.
Rather than sequentially,
you just sort of stop
and you go to another one.
OK.
Size effects I'm not
going to say a lot about,
because they're kind of obvious.
There's the obvious
part of size effect
that if your system has
some periodicity that
doesn't fit in your box,
you're kind of messing up
your system essentially.
You're forcing on a periodicity
which it doesn't have.
And so if it's a
solid state system,
often what's going to do is make
some kind of phase boundaries
to try to fit into it.
So that's an obvious one,
that if your system has
real periodicity
your box size should
be commensurate with
that periodicity.
It's kind of the obvious thing.
The other obvious thing--
if your system is really
way too small, you can
start seeing interaction
between the perturbation
in your Monte Carlo box
and its image coming from the
periodic boundary conditions.
But usually you've got to
have pretty small systems
to actually run into that.
And then there's a
sort of classic problem
of near second-order
transitions.
Near second-order transitions,
the fluctuations in a system
go towards infinity.
The correlation length of the
fluctuation becomes infinite,
and at the transition
it's actually infinite.
So for example, if you do this
ferromagnet, it spins all up,
and it was a
second-order transition,
there will be whole patches of
spins kind of flipping over.
And the spatial
correlation over distance
over which they do
that becomes infinite
at the second-order transition.
That means there
will be a point where
your cell is by definition
not large enough
to capture those fluctuations.
And essentially what
happens is that if you
work with a finite cell,
you remove all fluctuations
below a certain wavelength.
Any wavelength that's
larger than your box,
those fluctuations are gone
essentially from your system.
So that does things
to the heat capacity.
Remember that the
heat capacity is
a measure of the fluctuations.
It's E squared average minus
E average squared essentially
over kT squared.
So this is the
really funny thing.
The heat capacity at a
second-order transition
depends on the system
size even when normalized.
So you calculate the heat
capacity of your system,
you normalize it by
the number of particles
or spins in your
system, you think
that's a constant
quantity-- it's not.
That depends on
your system size.
And that's what I've shown here.
This is actually not
the heat capacity,
it's the susceptibility
variant of it.
So it's the fluctuation of the
spin rather than the energy.
But look at it.
This is for a ferromagnet.
This is a small size.
This is a 5 by 5
lattice, the green thing.
This blue thing here is a 10
by 10, 20 by 20, 30 by 30,
50 by 50.
And so what you
see is the bigger
your system, the bigger
your heat capacity.
And I don't know--
if we did it right, it should
go like the square root of n
essentially, where n is
the number of particles
in your system.
This is a great
thing to remember.
If you see phase
transitions in your system,
if you want to know whether
their first or second-order,
this is the test to do if
you absolutely want to know.
We'll talk later in
more detail about how
to see phase transitions.
But if you want to
be absolutely sure,
you'll often see humps
in susceptibilities
so susceptibilities I mean
second-order derivatives
of free energy--
source heat capacities
magnetic susceptibilities
chemical susceptibilities,
all those things tend to
show peak behavior near phase
transitions.
But you'll often
see peaks in them
even when you're not out
at a phase transition.
And the way to know that
it's a second or transition
is often just to look at the
scaling with system size.
I think I talked
about this last time--
keep in mind that if
you do to Monte Carlo,
you can pretty much
choose any types of moves.
And I talked last time
about diffusion-like moves
and exchange moves.
One thing I wanted to
kind of point out--
let me see if I still--
I'll do it here.
Sometimes looking
carefully at your system
can really help you do moves.
I'll give you an example.
A while ago I was
studying oxygen transport
on platinum surfaces.
And it's sort of the same.
Like in hydrogen on
palladium, in this case
it's a platinum 1 1 1, So
it's a triangular lattice.
But you have oxygen sitting
on particular lattice sites.
But because of some
reason, the oxygen
wanted to form strong
triplet clusters.
So that means on different
place in the labs
you all had these
triplet clusters.
So I'm drawing on a lattice.
As you can't see it, but anyway.
If your perturbation
mechanism is moving one oxygen
or flipping one oxygen
into a vacant site,
the dynamics of these kind of
systems becomes really poor.
And the reason is--
remember, if you
anneal the system, what
it's going to do its form
these triplet clusters.
But then what you'll
find in your Monte Carlo
is you can't move them anymore.
Because these clusters
then will have
to arrange in some
pattern, but you're
going to have really poor
convergence in your Monte
Carlo.
And what's the reason?
The only way that you
can displace this thing
is by breaking it up.
Because the perturbation
you assign is I take this,
and I make it into
a vacant site.
But now you break
up the triplet or I
want to start a new one here.
But it's the triplet clusters
that are very stable,
then all these perturbations
of breaking one
up or starting a new
one and going at them
are very high in energy.
So what essentially happens
is that your Monte Carlo
doesn't move anymore.
Because any excitation
you've given
it is very high in energy.
Even though the system may
have low energy excitations,
it may be moving this
whole thing over.
It sort of keeps the
triplet together.
And if there's a weak energy
interaction with them,
that's a low energy excitation.
So sometimes, especially at low
temperature, what you should do
is look at your system.
And especially if there
are stable ordered units
that form-- for
example, those could
be molecular units
if you're doing
an off lattice for molecular
simulation-- sometimes
it then pays to move
those things as a whole.
It can be a much more
efficient perturbation.
It becomes, of course,
more complicated to do
those kind of moves.
This is by far the
biggest problem
I see in complicated systems,
equilibrating complex systems.
They tend to have
multiple energy scales.
And as soon as you
freeze out one of them,
it becomes hard to even
equilibrate the lower energy
scale.
OK.
So let me sort of do a
very different system now,
to give you an idea
of how you can do--
what kind of perturbations
you can pick.
So now, instead
of Ising magnets--
Ising magnet is one with
two states up and down--
we'll look at a
Heisenberg magnet.
A Heisenberg magnet is one in
which you have a fixed spin,
but it can rotate
continuously in space.
So it can take any direction
in space not discretized.
So the spin vector has three
components, x, y, and z.
The Hamiltonian is very similar
to an Ising Hamiltonian.
You can define the interaction
energy through the dot product.
So again, the dot product
of the spins are parallel,
the dot product is 1.
If they're antiparallel,
the dot product is minus 1.
If they're orthogonal, it's 0.
And then you can have
anything in between.
So again, the j has a
very similar meaning.
Positive j will give
you ferromagnets,
negative j will give
you antiferromagnets.
And you can have a field term
or a chemical potential term
to control the amount of spin.
So how would we do Monte Carlo
perturbations on this system?
Well, first we need
a coordinate system.
And rather than x, y, z, if
we can serve the amount spin,
we can just use a set of
spherical coordinates, theta,
phi, and R. so
essentially you need
three coordinates to give
the direction of a vector.
And that's all we need,
since the norm, the length
of the vector, is conserved.
And this is one of
these ones where
maybe if you didn't think
carefully right away,
you'd pick theta
and phi randomly.
So remember, theta
can go anywhere from--
so what's the range of theta--
let's say 0 to 180, because the
vector can go all the way down.
And phi has a range of 0 to 360.
This one can go
all the way around.
Now, if you picked theta and
phi randomly in that interval,
you'd make a big mistake.
And the reason is, if
you think about it,
when you're at
theta equals 0, then
all the states for
phi, from 0 to 360,
map onto the same state.
So you'd very
often end up there.
Whereas if theta
equals 90 degrees,
so you're in this plane,
then all the states
for phi, from 0 to 460
are different states.
So essentially, when the density
with which you sample theta
should depend on its value.
Let me show that
in another slide.
For a given theta,
the number of states
that have that angle theta
is proportional to the slice
of the sphere.
So it's proportional
to 2pi sine theta.
This should be a d theta.
So it's proportional to
the area that you curve out
from the sphere.
So really what you
need to do is you
need to pick theta proportional
to sine theta d theta
or proportional to
sine theta really.
Because sine theta
is 0 and theta is 0,
so there are very
few states here.
And there's maximum
amount of states
around the sphere when you're
at theta equals 90 degrees.
So how do you do that?
You have to go from a
homogeneous distribution
of random numbers, which I've
taken for convenience here
as going from minus 1 to
1, rather than from 0 to 1,
and you want to go
to a random variable
now that's distributed
with a frequency.
You're going to go to a random
distribution between 0 and 180
if you're working for an angle.
But you want it
to be distributed
like the sine of theta.
And I've taken 1/2 sine of
theta so that the integral
under that curve is 1.
So what you need to do
is find some relation
between theta and
x, since x is what
you're going to pick from
your random number generator
and theta is what you
sample, so that theta
is distributed like that.
And the way you can do that is
you can actually write it out.
I've written down the solution.
But the way you find
that is by saying
that in a given
interval around theta,
you should have the same status
as a given interval around x.
So that means that p theta
d theta has two equal px dx,
and this is 1/2 sine
of theta d theta.
Px is 1/2, because it's
normalized there as 1/2 dx.
So I lose this, I lose this.
So d data dx is--
sorry.
Cross this out.
Dx d theta is the sine of theta.
That means that x is
minus the cosine of theta.
And that means that theta
is the arccosine of minus x.
So it's the cosine minus 1.
So this is how you can go from
a flat homogeneous distribution
to some other distribution.
So if you pick the
angles, with this function
you'll actually get a properly
distributed value of theta.
And then, of course,
phi, the other angle--
what do call that
again, I always
forget get the names of these--
you can pick randomly
from 0 to 360.
Oh, come on.
OK.
Let me actually, before
I show, go to a result.
What I've done here is set up a
ferromagnetic Heisenberg model
and looked at the heat capacity.
I'm actually not sure
this is ferromagnetic,
but it's a Heisenberg model.
But this is the
temperature axis,
and this is the heat capacity.
And I'm going to tell
you in a second-- this
is the way it's supposed
to look, the bottom thing.
But this is actually
how it looks.
At lower temperature get
higher heat capacity,
and then it kind of bends over.
And this piece is wrong.
So I did exactly the
algorithm that I told.
I implemented the distribution
for theta correctly,
and I sort of
randomly picked angles
to look for perturbations.
And this is what I get.
And the first time I
saw this, I remember,
ah, there must be a
phase transition here,
because there's a sort of
maximum in heat capacity.
But there actually isn't.
Because I'll show in a
second, if you do it right,
you get the heat capacity
slide on the bottom here.
Keep in mind that heat capacity
is sampling fluctuations.
So if you do something wrong
and you don't allow your system
to fluctuate enough, you
will reduce its heat capacity
artificially.
And that's what's
going on there.
I'm basically not
doing a good job
about sampling
certain fluctuations,
and that's why the heat
capacity, as I go towards 0,
spuriously goes down.
And it's interesting, because
these fluctuations that I'm
missing have no counterpart
in discrete models,
like lattice models.
In this model, what they
actually are are spin waves.
And that's the previous slide.
In a lattice model, the
lowest energy fluctuation
is a finite amount of energy
above the ground state.
If you think of your
ferromagnetic model,
what's the lowest
energy fluctuation?
Flipping one0 spin over.
Remember, I told you
that cost you 8j--
that's the energy cost.
It's a finite number
above the ground state.
In a continuous
model, you usually
have excitations that are
an infinitesimal amount
above the ground state.
That means these
fluctuations are
reachable at any temperature.
Because if they're an
infinitesimal amount
above the ground
state, you can get them
as soon as T is
infinitesimally amount above 0.
And in a Heisenberg model,
then equivalent thing
are spin waves.
We may have thought that
we have a ferromagnet,
and the lowest
order fluctuation is
to take one spin and kind
of randomly orient it.
Well, they're not.
The lowest energy
fluctuation is a spin wave.
It's literally sort of
like the wave in a stadium,
where everybody moves a little.
It's essentially where you move
every spin just a little bit
correspondent to the next one.
And if you actually
calculate the energy of that
and you take the long
wave length limit,
you find that the
energy is actually
only an infinitesimal amount
above the ground state--
so for the infinite wavelength.
And as the wavelength
gets shorter,
the energy of the
fluctuation goes up.
So you can see now
that we don't get
that in our sampling algorithm.
And the reason is that we're
just never efficient enough
to perturb states where
you have just these really
small amounts of spin canting
over a very long wavelength.
Because what do we do?
Think about it.
If we're in a ferromagnetic
state, what are we going to do?
With our algorithm, we're
going to be picking a spin
and taking a random
new orientation.
And we're never
going to accept it.
If you're a low enough
temperature that's
finite energy perturbations,
you're not going to accept it.
OK.
So how do you fix this problem?
Well, if you
understand the physics,
you start building it in.
You start taking
other perturbations.
And here's a very
simple solution to it--
if you have a spin at
a given orientation,
rather than finding a random
new orientation of the spin,
you say, I'm going to randomize
it just within a small cone.
So I'm only allowing a
certain amount of deviation
from that angle.
And as you make that
smaller and smaller,
you'll start
getting speed waves.
Because every spin will only be
perturbed a very small amount
of time.
You're essentially just
making your sampling algorithm
a lot more efficient.
And if you do that, you
get this heat capacity.
So it's perfect.
Notice that the heat
capacity is finite at 0,
did you expect that?
I mean, heat capacity cannot
be non-zero at 0 Kelvin.
If you have finite
heat capacity, so
heat capacity that's not
0 at 0 degrees Kelvin,
you have infinite entropy.
Because remember, the
entropy is the integral
of C V over T V T. S is heat
capacity at any heat capacity
essentially.
So if this goes to 0,
this has to go to 0.
Because otherwise this
integral blows up.
And heat capacity
always goes to 0.
So there's something
wrong with the model.
And what's wrong with it?
What's wrong with it is
kind of what I pointed out,
that it has these
infinitesimally
small excitation energies,
because it's a continuum model.
In any real system, remember
that the states are quantized.
That means that the first
excitation is always
a finite energy above
the ground state.
And you see, this is important.
If you're a finite energy
above the ground state,
there will always be some
temperature that's low enough
to freeze out that excitation.
If your first excitation
is 1 millielectron-volt
above the ground state,
you can do the math.
When kT is about 1
millielectron-volt,
below that temperature
will start freezing
out that excitation,
and it won't contribute
to the heat capacity anymore.
And this is how heat
capacities go to 0.
It's because energy states
are in reality quantized.
So any time you work
with a continuum model--
let me restate that--
I mean, a model with
continuous degrees of freedom--
this was one, the
Heisenberg angle--
atoms moving, like a continuous
set of coordinates in space,
will give you a finite
heat capacity at 0 Kelvin.
And that's wrong.
So how should you solve that.
Well, that's a
difficult problem.
The way to solve
that is you will
have to know what the
quantized excitations are.
And if you had atoms, there your
continuous degree of freedom
is a displacement.
So what's the quantized
degree of freedom there?
Atoms in a solid.
Remember, if you do this on a
solid, just displace the atoms
small amounts, you'll get
non-zero heat capacity.
So how do you quantize the
displacement degree of freedom
in a solid?
Those are called phonons.
It's by phonon diagonalization
that you find the eigenstates.
So those are the quantum states,
and they are a finite area
above the ground state.
What are they in a
Heisenberg magnet?
I don't know, and I
think nobody knows.
Finding the eigenstates
of a Heisenberg model
seems to be a really
difficult problem that
to my understanding
is not fully resolved.
So we don't even know what the
eigenstates are of the system
if you wanted to do
it fully quantized.
In an Ising model, we know.
They're actually trivial.
The eigenstates are states
with just one spin perturbed
from say plus 1 to minus 1.
So there we're actually
getting the right excitations
as we go to the ground
state, as we go to 0.
In atoms in solids,
we know what they are.
They're phonons.
Those are the eigenstates
for the displacements
of the system.
In a model like this, we
don't know what they are.
OK.
Other things-- if you go
through more complex geometries,
the kind of perturbation
algorithms in Monte Carlo
get successively more
complicated and tedious.
And I'll give you
an example of it.
Let's say you do a long
chain molecule, a polymer.
This is sort of a simplified
version of a polymer.
It's to kind-- you remove
all the degrees of freedom
from the side group,
so it's essentially
a chain because
of the fixed angle
of a certain
carbon-carbon bonds.
It can only rotate
along these bonds.
So often for a
polymer, people don't
use all the possible
degrees of freedom.
They say, well, an sp2
or an sp3 carbon bond
has a certain angle.
So all I can do is
rotate around that angle
so that I keep
that bonding angle.
So it essentially restricts
the rotation degrees
of freedom of every carbon joint
along the polymer chain axis.
So what then you have to do
is you have to sample space
with those degrees of freedom.
And I've given here an example.
Let's say you want
to start rotating
this end of the chain
from that carbon.
So you would essentially
keep this fixed
and kind of swing the
rest of the chain around.
But what you see
is that these are
going to be very
inefficient algorithms.
Because if this is a really
long chain, if you just
do a small omega,
you're kind of swinging
that far end of the
chain really far,
and it's going to
bump into other atoms.
So people use these
kind of algorithms.
But if you read the
literature of how
to do Monte Carlo
on polymers not
on lattices or in
real space, it's
full of all kinds
of tricks to find
good perturbations that
make these algorithms more
efficient.
But in the end, it is
a difficult problem.
Because the problem
with a polymer
or any long
biological molecule is
that it's really hard
to find excitations
that sample all your
degrees of freedom
but that don't make a
large piece of your chain
bump into other things.
Because, you see, the
annoying thing about polymers
is that, yes, your atoms can
move freely a little bit,
but they are all connected.
And building in that
constraint in the perturbation
is not trivial.
Those of us who work with
small molecules and atoms
have it much easier.
They are sort of--
the perturbations tend
to be relatively trivial.
OK, I got to move on.
Because of this, often people
do polymers on a lattice.
And you can do that
reasonably well.
I mean, I'll show you a
trivial version of it,
but people have much
more sophisticated.
A really simple way
of putting a polymer
is by snaking it on a lattice.
So this may be every bead.
So you say, well, this is sort
of a polymer snaking around.
And people have even
built lattice models
that are much denser, where
every segment of the polymer--
where there's a lot
more lattice points
than segments of the polymer.
So the density of
lattice points--
there are much
more lattice points
per unit length of the
polymer, so that you
start to approach a continuum.
So the lattice
algorithms are sort
of an important
class of Monte Carlo
algorithms in polymer dynamics.
So how would you,
let's say, perturb--
let's say this is your polymer.
How would you do Monte
Carlo perturbations on that?
How would you--
First of all, let me
tell you an obvious way.
You could rebuild that polymer.
So what's the length there?
1, 2, 3, 4,5, 6,
7, 8, 9, 10, 11.
So you could build essentially
all self-avoiding random walks
of length 11.
And that is the ensemble of
your polymer of chain length 11.
Now, because its 11, that's
actually quite doable.
But, of course, if we go to
50, that's not doable anymore.
I get to see all kinds of
other things here on the TV.
So you can't see that.
So how would you do
an algorithm to sort
of perturb chains like that?
Remember, it doesn't have
to be realistic as long
as it samples your space.
I'm just going to stand
here until I get an answer.
Look at that.
How would you perturb
that snake essentially?
Come on.
You have to come up with
at least one scheme.
So there are three or
four different types
of perturbations you can do
on that in sampled space.
Remember, the idea
is, how can you
make this thing
move on the lattice
and take on different
configurations?
I think you've pointed--
I'm pretty sure that
what you said is right.
AUDIENCE: Like, you just
cut it and regrow it.
GERBRAND CEDER: Yeah.
You can cut it and regrow it.
There's definitely
a way you do it.
So again, rather than
sampling the whole random walk
of the long polymer,
you can just
cut it and regrow a part of it.
When you do that, you've got
to be really careful that you
do your whole sampling
statistics right for the parts
that you keep.
But with these you can
actually do simple things.
Like here's an obvious one--
you can take the end, this
end here, and fluctuate it.
Like you could say,
take this segment
and make it go
either here or here.
You could slide
the snake forward.
So you could say, I'm going
to put a vector on this
and move this forward one.
So that means--
I randomly pick where
I put the next segment.
So I take this segment.
So that means I can either
slide it to here or to here,
and I slide the
whole snake forward.
That's essentially the same as--
the way people often describe
is, I take the end piece
and I put it on the front
with a random orientation.
You can do other things.
You can do what's
called the King jump.
See this is whenever you
have a sort of square corner,
you can kink it
over and do this.
Again, that's a
symmetric perturbation.
You can just as easily go from
here to here, then from here
to here.
In 3D that's called a
crank crankshaft jump.
Because in 3D, if I can--
let's say you have
a polymer like this.
You can rotate this
piece like a crankshaft.
You can do those kind
of perturbations.
So you can pretty much
choose the kind of things
that you want to do.
OK.
OK, let me stop here.
This is kind of a new topic.
So I'll pick that up--
today's Tuesday-- so I
guess on Thursday then.
So I'll you Thursday.